hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play or I rather
let's take a look at grinning this is
just the demo but this is a really a new
game but very interesting looking game
it's completely custom built engine it's
a game that apparently took 3.5 years
but it's got about no attention and I
saw it and I saw the gameplay video and
it looked really interesting so I just I
really want to take a look at it so hope
you guys will enjoy it's supposed to be
like a spooky 2d platformer style game I
mean really the gameplay was very
interesting there's links in the
description blue emptiness like nice
soon emptiness everywhere
how does emptiness taste like no
happiness no pain no hope cold it's
freezing to me wait me Who am I am i
alive I feel something something weird
Oh No what's going on oh yeah so you're
like this little groundhog thingy I saw
how do we move see ah
whoo I can move alarm ah ah my head ah
where am i ah why is it so dark in here
so the monsters can get you gosh I can't
remember anything
what is this place I'm pretty sure a
groundhog doesn't have a deeper voice is
mine but we're gonna go with it okay uh
what is it please
there we go okay now you move WASD
look around with mouse ooh I like this
it's dark okay
wait where am I I'm in the same box I
was what happened
hello what is that what's going on here
huh girl it was my little arms girl bruh
we can grab on oh okay Oh interesting uh
did something happen was ice posted oh
there we go
whoa hello yeah what's really impressive
is that this whole engine is built very
custom like and it reminded me a bit of
like how limbo was with the environment
moving around and actually does more now
it just was looked really cool and I
couldn't believe that no one had oh
hello Jimmy girl I got a box what's
wrong
look at me ha ha what am I doing with
this yeah but it's key oh come on hey hi
come here yeah come here so so fat there
we go okay yeah yeah oh man this is
really cool I like it in the same way as
boxes you can catch ropes and travel in
the air Oh what oh ah I'm too high up
momentum not working yeah is the water
deadly I think maybe ah very nice yeah
this is this is a full yeah oh it's not
deadly uh whoops I'm just bad at the
whole platformer dealio and I am just
playing the demo but I already think
that I'm gonna buy this game because it
is awesome and something that I've
always wanted to do you know with my
channel is being able to support indie
developers and this this definitely
deserves it it is Wow maybe I don't know
I haven't seen the rest of the game I'll
hold judgment cuz you know I shouldn't
right away or maybe it is exactly as it
looks and it's really cool I do like the
atmosphere the music school in the
background and the way the lighting
works on the kind of pitch-black
environment everywhere I see a level up
there a lever up there yeah how can how
can I reach whoa oh how does it play in
the foreground how can I reach it ah how
can I get up there all right this way ha
ha Oh found it
what's this then huh bro carried object
yeah
yes interesting ha ah ah here we go
ah very very car I actually really do
like puzzle platforms I'm not good at
them cuz I'm not good at puzzles but oh
hey I got clothes high-angle ha ha no ha
ha ha ha ha I'm such a boss ok wait do I
the box here let's let's not throw it
just yet let's do this here ha yeah yes
Wow
ha ha
and the best in groundhog ever whether
those look like eyes I did those look
like eyes what's going on here
oh hello oh man Oh like oh man this is
more physically this really physically
info that the description of the game is
also very it's also supposed to be a
horror game who's that so you got like I
love it oh it's very very physically
inclined what is that hello hi
okay who's breathing there is so dark
oh okay it's a bad idea to go there okay
whatever you say buddy I'm not going
there who keep seeing things jutting out
in the foreground and it kind of told me
i ah I died screw you I did not know
that I was there okay so don't touch
that platform huh ah yeah there we go
what a shiny stone there it might be
useful
ah I wasn't an idiot here we go again
huh I don't know when this Hedgehog got
a British accent but he'll did huh
I'm not obviously not the best gameplay
at try these really interesting and
innovative minigames because I sucked
Happ now ah Depp da cunha ha ha here we
go ha ha huh
what was up here Oh spikes that's what I
was up here
oh okay so definitely should not die
here haha
don't die oh I'm so good
okay here we go hello hello hello
no it's awfully dark up here is anybody
home
anybody oh my arm
yeah uh well I guess I didn't need it
cuz it's bright now hop yeah I wouldn't
have been able to keep it trying to jump
across these vines anyway so ha ha
why did I go for that huh
why did I go for that ha ha ha okay come
here
yeah oh okay Bob I thought you could
grab on to it it was just a tween okay
take five
ah come here connect me woo woo that is
a hard jump okay here we go
ah holy crap did not think I was gonna
make that one oh that is definitely acid
this fluid smells bad you smell that
we're freaking groundhog or Hedgehog I'm
not even exactly sure what you are but
you're sentient okay too high up just go
to drop down a little bit yeah there we
go sorry I'm gonna make it I'm gonna
make it I'm not that bad
I say as I fail ah ha ha
perfect oh man this is stressful oh man
but really I got it I got a reiterate
that this game apparently took 3.5 years
to make and I don't blame them because
this is pretty cool we custom-built the
engine all the lighting
what is that hello out there
haha ah balls okay hello
hang on hello hello ah miss me
hahaha I'm the Beth was it was this pile
of goop yeah get get push abyss shoot a
pursuit limbo I love her gonna fish you
haha
oh there's many of you I bish I love you
you sure Oh what
dead end nah ah time to pile up these
weird things that makes no sense you're
in some weird underground cavern
what does anything make sense hey
apparently at the beginning this game
you weren't even alive so I think your
lucky stars your whatever the hell you
wear and in the beginning I didn't even
realize how did you know it a head was
huh yep yeah huh come on Wow there we go
one more huh okay haha come on
ha yeah oh come on how dare you [ __ ]
I'm gonna whatever you are you
pilot dead leaves aerial ha got it yeah
got it got it got it got it got it
nailed it nail it nail it nail it
nailing it nailing it nailing it tucked
now where did it leave there we go hmm
pretty very pretty I like it a lot hmm
leaving down the weird intestines into
nowhere
I guess that's the Oh darker you what is
that huh weird sounds yeah no kidding
haha hello moment there is something
wrong
oh boy you ain't Ken man sound is
getting louder they were worried hello
yeah definitely ok ha I see eyes ha ha
ha holy crap what the [ __ ] was that just
run run [ __ ] what is that ah Holly crap
get effect you get away get away get
away what are you usually little box
things ah yeah I oh there's more oh gosh
you holy crap do I
oh man hello hi I'm waving at ya I hope
we never meet that iam hey how do you
know who we is Chuck boy autosave yeah
I'm definitely gonna buy this game
because this game is awesome
obviously links in the description below
I can't read all right
haha I can't reiterate how cool this
game isn't like I had like no one oh
hello
hi check behind oh oh I'm falling
falling and unknown how to end that
chapter 2 falling down the demo contains
two chapters so he just beat the first
I'm gonna I'm this making a make it all
in one video because this is just cool -
cool - stop what are you doing here I
don't know just taking a stroll
yo testing out my legs which I didn't
have 15 minutes ago
oh okay yeah I cannot reiterate how cool
I think my mind is cheating on you that
[ __ ] who does she I felt really loud
voice inside water very cool yeah I
can't reiterate how cool this game is I
haven't been able to finish that thought
and it had like no no one no attention
on nd DB which and it has its own
website where you can actually buy the
game it was just really cool and there
was like no I couldn't believe it there
was no one that you know had anything to
say about this game and I I really hope
that this helps it out because and this
is awesome this is like this is like on
par if not uh you know it cooler in a
lot of ways in limbo because it is oh
wait I see those leaves I can probably
climb that look leaves on the wall cat
meow good yes okay because it is like
seriously I'm not even joking it's
ridiculously awesome okay enough enough
enough ass-kissing more gameplay hey
come on I see you there ah all right so
what did that did I don't think I take
to fall damage when they pick it up
there hat uh-huh yeah yeah a secret no
no okay German tap that I made it okay
um what does it do oh I see okay sploosh
hello hello is anybody harm
oh I can't breathe I'm drowning oh okay
I was like what is that swallowing oh
I'm drowning oh okay that makes sense
okay through again Oh get on my way
rocks I'll get on my way rocks I don't
have time for your BS oh nothing
look ah ah okay back in the water yeah
makes me think was the engine for limbo
custom made I don't know I mean I would
think it would be most of these 2d
platformers are ah come on I'm trying to
I'm trying to the rocks
I can't rocks aerial that's a big enough
get no it's not I'm parently suck too
fat to get through there oh come on oh
come on get out here ah I died Paul's ha
right in the drink okay so apparently I
can't hold my breath and nearly as long
as I thought I could can like barely do
it for two seconds before I drown okay
here we go that little wet down here
come on come on you [ __ ] oh come on I
thought I'd rather have a little too
close little emitter oh my gosh ahhhh oh
my gosh ahhhh ah there we go yeah by way
I'm try to get there now squirt
Fleur Fleur du ER okay you're real ya
gotta get the ones from the top first I
think that's super smart way to go no no
it's not cuz it can't boss back yeah ah
ah coming huh yeah this isn't because
the puzzle is hard it's because I suck I
am terrible add here we go alright yeah
almost got it huh oh yeah okay alright
get enough air here we go finally coming
through
about damn time market bar sucks
ah there we go checkpoint back
checkpoints it's glowy ball get a glowy
ball we're going on in Adventure whoo
we're going on an adventure
yeah no ah yes
come here we're going on an adventure
this way - screw that way that way
stupid in whoa and what's that looks
like kind of chambers ah labels oh no oh
oh you an ow okay let me first whose
eyes multi no checkpoint what why are
you here this place isn't safe yeah no
kidding jeez if monsters everywhere
this thing is speaking directly into my
mind yeah you going crazy just like as
clerk oh I see hat little alleged here
yeah yeah
fire bad fire bad okay oh I thought that
was a little kid standing there was a
lever again okay
click like would that do don't do
anything didn't do anything maybe it did
something
hello fire how am I gonna get out of
here
how am I gonna get out of here okay I
see some leaves up on top that I could
climb out but Hana how am the hell oh I
see two leads to the bottom here
ha yep this oh yeah oh oh oh oh oh so
pro ha ok anything over here
what was this nothing okay moving it
forward looking for
huh uh-huh I don't know if you take fall
damage as you fall wait how do I wait
what
well the bridge has moved what wait man
some done feel right here huh some some
some not right
I don't know I'm detecting something not
right here when I did not detect that
quite obvious trap when I wasn't even
that obvious that trap with the yellow
thing why is that
twitch wobbling now why you be wobble
things you're behaving strangely
hello another one Oh what's this oh I
see victim bridge a once I get in it I
can get out okay and probably stop what
that is this was this just like some
support for that thing is that gonna
oh hello echo yes yes yes I like now I
just need to put the red one and the
yellow one in at the same time huh okay
look come on oh oh oh you got it oh
maybe I can maybe I can't go in it at
the same time ah there we go
huh what we've done bridge here we go
give me out here come out here I said
get me out of here
I can't stand being in here for another
second coming
give me my orb orb of power go uh well
what what am I supposed to do maybe I
keep it no I can't do that
come here what about what am i but to do
okay this is where I am stupid
let's see here maybe this makes a sound
when I move but not when I stop gotta be
something gotta be some this seems like
there's a little transparent part in
that pillar but apparently not okay so
if I just ha oh that's how you do it
okay so I am much stronger than I
thought I was oh not not quite almost
there almost there almost there
ha ohh too low too low low must go
higher higher ha ha ah little bit too
low I can get this I'm gonna spend the
next 30 minutes right here just trying
to get it through this little hole 30
minutes later my mine another hour later
Oh
okay that was my fault I clearly yes I
clearly saw I clearly saw that there was
a hollow point in in the middle there ah
okay what the hell oh crap oh where did
you where did you ought to save me Oh
where did you autosave me oh no you did
not
oh no you did not oh you did not oh I
will murder your entire family all you
did holy [ __ ] you did oh my god are you
kidding me
holy crap you did what the hell
no I are you kidding me are you kidding
me holy crap No what the hell
Oh No if you guys don't know what just
happened it sent me back ten minutes ago
and I mean I'll get through it quicker
now but geez holy crap I can't believe
they wouldn't have an autosave after
that my god that is that is absolutely
incredible oversight I mean I understand
that I took a long time on that puzzle
when I shouldn't have it I mean the
solution was right in front of my face
when there but holy crap that is a lot
of progress to not have a save for my
goodness alright anyway I'm gonna ignore
that because a lot of that was my fault
don't fault the game taker for my
mistakes
mark I'm doing okay so don't follow the
game maker for my own mistakes it's
Burton that's rule number one I made a
mistake there I knew that I knew that
jellies were gonna come out well I
didn't know that I thought that they
only came out when I put the yellow one
but apparently not too big of an idiot
to even contemplate that I may be making
a grievous error anyway so carrying on
and now that I know the answer to this
one it won't take dear
long unless I'm an even bigger idiot
than I thought I was I'm okay so
carrying on I'm definitely gonna you
guys didn't see that the entirety that
was the mistake that I made really
stupid
did we mistake like if I cut it out I
was trying to throw this ball way up
there when I should have just thrown it
through this little hole here it would
have gone by itself but I did not
because I'm an idiot and there we go
see that's the solution don't do
whatever you didn't see me do and we'll
be good okay so carrying on we we having
happy fun times okay so moving forward
moving forward moving forward and so
what do I do when I have both of these
like if the monsters come out
immediately like what do I do I don't
even know I don't even know what to do
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna push
this in and drop this in and then get
the hell out of here oh no no oh no oh
no oh no oh no not again
are you kidding me well what the hell
it's it's a yellow chamber and a red
chamber what am I supposed to do besides
put them both in what am I supposed to
do oh no I just did didn't I
put him in the other chambers okay wow
that was obvious okay Matan might not
even be the solution but here we go
again going back about five minutes to
get the red orb ah heck you know
actually now that I'm thinking about
that's probably not the solution I don't
even know what what I'm trying what
puzzle I'm trying to solve here it's not
very clear what my objective is or why I
should do that but apparently getting
the yellow in the yellow causes getting
the red in the red and the yellow yellow
causes monsters to spawn which is bad
okay
all right very bad they breach has moved
good good good yeah that's good yeah
okay the bridge has moved the bridge has
moved all right
seriously um though even though this is
frustrating for me this is a puzzle
platformer and I have made it very clear
that I'm bad at puzzle platformers ergo
it's not really that big of a deal that
I've made these mistakes that I have
because it's not the game fault it is
not it is not I do not blame the
developer for my mistakes I stopped
doing if I'm frustrated if it seems like
I'm frustrated it's only because I'm
frustrated at myself for the mistakes
that I have made ergo I do not blame the
developer in the least see no blame so
hope that alleviates a lot of the
questioning that was going on that I
know is happening lay oh why you so mad
brah umad brah
I'm not mad
I'm now mad there we go okay go no it's
not it's not gone oh no oh no don't
don't don't you mess with me now okay
here we go trying to get through this as
best I can because it is pain and asked
pain and us okay so maybe maybe the
totes mix croats non-obvious of putting
the red and the yellow is gonna be the
solution to this puzzle that I don't
even know what it's gonna solve yay okay
Oh
well now that is the solution that's
fantastic hahaha is so great I love it
okay Cheers I'm not blaming the game but
yeah it's kinda color coordination is a
basic game skill that is taught from a
very early age but because I put the
yellow in the yellow in beginning and it
spawned the monsters I assume that is
because I put them in the wrong order
that I need to put the red first and
then the yellow it's it knocking okay
then I should have learned sooner okay
died anyway moving forward moving
forward just moving forward
okay here we go head up head up hello Oh
God running out of air
what am I gonna do I'm gonna die about
die nobody air but no air there was no
air whatever he doing what are you doing
we're breathing again whatever there was
no air there was no air
maybe there's air like up here aha there
is okay secret air secret air huh going
back in the drink OOP Oh Oh can't
breathe again secret air air air air
fudge alright then
no secret air for me
that's East Boosh into the secret air
catch my breath okay where could there
be another air pocket there's got to be
one I mean it's not just gonna let me go
that whole distance without one right
right right
wait in this darkness area I'll come on
there's no air
why is it no air there's got to be here
maybe I thought I was maybe moving too
though moving to the right there at that
last portion but here we go let me try
it again
okay so I see moving moving moving
moving moving moving moving moving
moving moving moving fast as I can fast
as I can
moving through the water as a fast as I
can know their dough's bar there I just
got a gun it I just got a gun it no
can't gun it well dad okay getting air
getting air may backer like put a bubble
around my head if I really think hard
huh
okay so maybe maybe I do just gotta gun
it as fast as I can that's why I'm gonna
try here now because I'm already running
out of oh yeah I get stuck on the leaves
ergo I'm never gonna make it holy crap
ha ha ha what uh hell oh man this is
this is not good what am I supposed to
do here maybe there's like a secret
passage where I don't go all the way up
and I can cut across somewhere so I look
for now nope nope nope
aha yeah ah genius genius genius I
learned that from Donkey Kong yeah ha ha
it's a trick is a tricky trick it's a
little tricky trick good thing I am
going Li smarty ha
Oh God get away get away get away get
away get away get away get away get away
get away ah ah no get away from me ah
don't pick the right vine pick the left
vine man game maker this one is a troll
to the max like just got [ __ ] with
you just [ __ ] with you man constant
Dickens
well no not dick he's done something
else I didn't pick the left oh come on
that balls breaking how am I supposed to
do anything they swarm me immediately
immediately they swarm me maybe I gotta
quickly jump from one to the other I
don't know no get away from me I would
be nice if I wasn't in immediate danger
okay here we go y'all ready for this
y'all ready for this Danny I'm gonna
immediately jump from one to the other
strategize Han na yeah I did it
yeah Oh get away ah screw you sure you
you're still following me screw you get
out of here get out of here ha ha yes
yeah they are chasing me
on every my step little typo they are so
powerful why don't you lift bra why you
know Thalia no one can stop them and
that's it that is the end of the demo of
grinning yeah I hope you all enjoyed it
even though I was frustrated toward the
end there like seriously that's not the
developers fault that he makes a
challenging game err it's not even that
challenging it was just stupidity on my
part either way at the core mechanics of
the game the game is really fun the game
is really really cool and interesting
it's not bad that I got stuck because
the puzzles themselves were very obvious
to solve once you found it it's not his
fault that I got stuck as you anyone
who's watched me before I am an idiot
when it comes to these games and I get
stuck all the time but I eventually got
through it and it didn't take that long
because I have this bad habit of once I
think a solution is a certain way I
happen to hammer it until it works
because you know usually in other games
that might help me but in some games
like this trying to think outside of the
solution that I've set my mind on is bad
but either way I highly recommend this
game it's not that much I think it's
like I don't know five ten dollars I'm
not sure but I'm gonna buy it I'm not
gonna do a full let's play of it but I'm
gonna buy just to support the developer
and I highly we're going to click the
link of the description below it leads
to their page on indie to be or I'll
probably link their direct website which
is where you can buy you can't buy it on
NDTV you can buy from their website
through PayPal so check out Grimm and if
you don't want to buy it play the demo
it was amazing I really really liked it
the atmosphere was great the gameplay
was great on those enemies it was really
spooky I want to see like what happens
towards the end that kind of makes it a
bit spooky er at the end because it was
very atmospheric and I when those things
were chasing me I felt like they're
really about to kill me and I could do
nothing which is a very good gameplay
mechanic in a horror game of survival or
especially in a 2d platformer survival
horror can't be nothing but good so
thank you all so much for watching be
sure to check out their website buy it
if you like
get tried if you don't and thank you so
much for watching click the annotation
form videos that I've done and as always
I will see you in the next video bye
you're real you're real what are you
though